I'd like for you to take a moment to
imagine this with me you're a little
girl of five years old sitting in front
of a mirror you ask yourself do I exist
in this space there is very little
context and so you move into a different
one one filled with people surely now
you know you're not a figment of your
own imagination you Breeze there you see
them so they must see you and yet you
still can't help but wonder do I only
exist when people speak to me pretty
every thoughts for a child right but
through various artworks that reflect
upon our society I came to understand
how a young black girl can grow up
feeling as if she's not seen and perhaps
she doesn't exist
you see if young people don't have
positive images of themselves and all
that remains a negative stereotypes this
affects their self-image but it also
affects the way that the rest of society
treats them I discovered this having
lived in Cape Town for about five years
at the time I felt a deep sense of
dislocation and invisibility I couldn't
see myself represented I couldn't see
the woman who raised me the ones who
have influenced me and the ones that
have made South Africa what it is today
I decided to do something about it what
do you think when you see this if you
are a black girl how would it make you
feel walking down the street what does
the city you live in say to you what
symbols are present which histories are
celebrated and on the other hand
which ones are omitted you see public
spaces are hardly ever as neutral as
they may seem I discovered this when I
made this performance in 2013 on
Heritage Day Cape Town is teeming with
masculine architecture monuments and
statues such as Louie Bertha in that
photograph this overt presence of white
colonial and Afrikaner nationalists men
not only echoes a social gender and
racial divide but it also continues to
affect the way that woman and the way
particularly black women see themselves
in relation to dominant male figures in
public spaces for this reason among
others I don't believe that we need
statues the preservation of history and
the act of remembering can be achieved
and more memorable and effective ways as
part of a year-long public holiday
series I use performance art as a form
of social commentary to draw people's
attention to certain issues as well as
addressing the absence of the black
female body in memorialized public
spaces especially on public holidays
woman's day was coming up I looked at
what the day means the woman's march to
the Union Buildings in 1956 petitioning
against the pass laws juxtaposed with
the hypocrisy of how women are treated
especially in public spaces today I
decided to do something about it
headline woman in miniskirts attacked a
taxi rank
how do I comment on such polar opposites
and the guise of my great-grandmother I
performed bare-breasted close to the
taxi rank in Quail anda this space is
also called Freedom Square where woman
were a part of demonstrations against
apartheid laws I was not comfortable
with women being seen as only victims in
society and you might wonder how people
reacted to this fake Oh ha so I realized
that through my performances I have been
able to make regular people reflect upon
the society looking at the past as well
as the current democracy she's been
there since - yeah
just before but I was too just a really
hot day and she's in the going about
when this happens
[Music]
hey interesting that's very powerful
you wanna Dickens hold
like a lot of people are like quick to
join like a group it's like a movement
towards something not many people are
ready to like do something as an
individual you know so it's an
individual versus the collective yeah so
I think
her pushing like her own individual
message and performance powerful yeah I
think it's quite powerful that she's
doing it on her own
I'd be interested to know why she's
using hair extensions as wings or
[Music]
standing where right now I think it's
just my interpretation that we are
bringing the station down and bringing
up something that's supposed to
represent something should stand well
okay this is behind mrs. represent the
African culture we can't have the
colonialist on conference we need to
remove all these colonists at us we have
to have our own status now our African
leaders but mostly women but all those
who they are lies for our liberation
circle we can continue twenty percent
and then twenty one years of democracy
serving the colonists in our own country
they belong some maybe in the music not
here I'm in the lemon institution that
places where they are people they are
monarch in shape so we cannot continue
clear blue sport of all these people
because they representing the holiday
listen on April 9th 2015
the John sessile Road statue was
scheduled to be removed
after a month of debates for and against
its removal by various stakeholders this
caused a widespread of interest in
statues in South Africa opinions varied
but the media focused on problematizing
the removal of statues on that well that
year I had just begun my masters at the
University of Cape Town during the time
of the debates of the statue I had been
having reoccurring dreams about a bird
and so I started conjuring her mentally
spiritually and through dress
on that day I happen to be having a
meeting with my supervisors and they
told me that the statue is gonna fall on
that day I told them that I'd explain
later but we had to postpone the meeting
because I was gonna perform her as the
statue came down her name was Choi Pongo
she was a soapstone bird that was looted
from Great Zimbabwe in the late 1800s
and is still currently housed and John
Cecil Rhodes estate in Cape Town on that
day I embodied her existence using my
body while standing in the Blazing Sun
for nearly four hours as the time came
the crane came alive the people did too
shouting screaming clenching their fists
and taking pictures of the moment on
their phones and cameras chiapas wings
along with the crane rose to deter the
fall of John Cecil Rhodes
euphoria filled the air as he became
absent from his base while she remained
still very present half an hour after
his removal 23 years after part eight a
new generation of radicals has arrived
in South Africa the story of Chippewa
and Rhodes in the in the same space and
time asks important questions related to
gender power self representation
history-making and repatriation from
then on
I realized that my spiritual beliefs and
dreams texture my material reality but
for me Chopin was story felt and
complete the soapstone bird a spiritual
medium and Messenger of God and the
ancestors needed me to continue her
story and so I doubled in the dream
space a little bit more and this is how
falling was born
I meet again
[Music]
my meeting
I mean
[Music]
in the film Zimbabwe South Africa and
Germany share a common story about the
soapstone birds that were looted from
Great Zimbabwe after Zimbabwe gained its
independence all the birds except for
one were returned to the monument
falling explores the mythological belief
that they will be unrest until the final
bird is returned through my work I have
realized a lot about the world around me
how we move through spaces who we choose
to celebrate and who we remember now I
look in the mirror and not only see an
image of myself but of the woman who
have made me who I am today I stand tall
and my work celebrating woman's
histories in the hope that perhaps one
day no little black girl has to ever
feel like she doesn't exist thank you
[Applause]
[Music]